hi there steve kaufman here today i want
to talk about pushkin
verbs of motion
and the internet
why
because i want to introduce
an outstanding teacher
a person who uses modern technology who
understands
the psychology of the learner and who is
very creative and i've discovered her
for my russian learning and therefore
for those of you who are learning
russian or either even interested in
seeing different ways of using
technology
i would like you i very much suggest you
go to the links that i'm going to put in
the explanation here in the description
of this video and watch the videos that
anna has created for her class she's a
an english teacher uh in saint
petersburg
at university there
and uh just see how cleverly she uses
modern technology to put together
very interesting videos about russia
i happen to have chosen the one about
pushkin but you'll see that there are
others in her collection
and also a video she's made on verbs of
motion which is a very difficult aspect
of russian
and of course
i can access this here's this person in
saint peterbury saint petersburg
developing wonderful material for her
class and it's available to the world
through the internet
i'm not stuck with say some less
capable teacher maybe at my local school
i can access teachers anywhere in the
world through the internet i think
that's just spectacular and if you look
at say the video about pushkin you'll
see that she repeats dates which is very
handy because dates are very difficult i
find in many languages
a number of things are repeated
it's done with humor
it's done
artistically
with pleasant music in the background
even if you aren't interested in pushkin
i think you become interested in pushkin
but again not everyone's going to be
interested in pushkin so you'll see that
she has a variety of videos about
russia and russian life russian history
and so forth
similarly in her approach to verbs of
motion you'll see that there's a a
minimal amount of explanation and a lot
of repetition
and a lot of um
assists in some of the visual
presentations of it anyway i think these
are extremely well done but i think the
fact that that the work of a person
somewhere in the world a teacher
can suddenly be available to people all
over the world
is is a wonderful example of the kind of
educational environment
we live in
so
please enjoy these videos and
thank you for listening bye for now